[Musik]
das podcast ist broadbent munich schön
sie zu sehen tut mir leid dass setzen
woche ausgefallen ist
aber jetzt geht's weiter das ist die
viertel veranstaltung im rahmen der
ringvorlesung sie erinnern sich
hoffentlich aus dass sie da waren
letztes mal ging es darum dass benjamins
projekt eigentlich relativ ambitioniert
ist es ist schon ein projekt das auch
klassischen philosophische aspekte ein
bildet nämlich die erkenntnis
theoretisch wir werden hier geht es um
die frage inwiefern ist die kunst auch
maßgeblich für das erkennen und das ist
nicht ausschließlich bei denen
beobachten diese fragestellung das hat
mir schon bei nietzsche hatte man schon
und gewissermaßen auch schon in der
romantik aber das sollte man nicht außer
acht lassen verbänden geht es um mehr
viel mehr als nur die frage ja gut ist
der film kunst oder ist es nicht kunst
oder was hier was hier eigenschaften hat
der film als als kunst es geht um die
frage wie erkennt man die welt was ist
wahrheit also die ganz klassischen
fragen was arbeit im zusammenhang mit
der kunst oder inwiefern ist kunst oder
künste kunst mäßiges wahrnehmen war es
üblich für das erkennen überhaupt ok und
das wiederum widerspiegelt die debatte
oder widerspiegelt eine zwei strömungen
dem zusammenschluss von zwei strömungen
die man zuletzt bei lukac georg lukács
beobachten konnte lukac als
literaturwissenschaftler der dann zum
marxismus nach dem ersten weltkrieg sich
hin wendet und diese these aufstellt
wonach erkenntnis nicht unmittelbar
wissenschaftler und
naturwissenschaftlich ist also quasi die
das klassische modell da ist die welt
ich erfasse die welt wissenschaftlich in
dem in dem ich meine ein theoretisches
können anbringen
das ist sogar der platonische gedanke
ist bei lukas verzichtet sie ja auf die
vorstellung einer objektiv erfassbaren
welt einfach da draußen und zerlegt sich
stattdessen auf dieses diese eliane
ische vorstellung einer zweiten natur
die zweite natur also die erste natur
ist das doch auch
die zweite natur ist das was der mensch
sich für sich selber herstellt und ist
insofern wandelbar also das ist dass das
fundamentale an dieser ganzen strömen
die vorstellung dass die welt das was
man beim erkennen erkennt und das
gegenstand der wahrheit ist dann wandel
war es ist nicht mehr einfach fix und
der natur wissenschaft zugänglich
sondern es ist eine zweite natur
die ist im historischen wandel begründet
ist okay die frage dann aber das hat mir
letztes mal die frage dann ist im
liefern kann ich nicht mit dieser
zweiten natur kritisch auseinandersetzen
also wie was ist jetzt die erkenntnis
ist das einfach auch etwas historisch
wandelbares und relatives bei lukac ist
nämlich das problem dass wir insofern
war erkennt das ist das
polizeikommissariat ist als subjekte
erkenntnis liegt der geschichte uns
objekte erkenntnis für luca das
impliziert dass zwar das proletariat gut
erkennen kann also wahrhafte erkenntnis
werben kann
aber was ist dann quasi die kritische
distanz zwischen dieser erkenntnis und
der welt überhaupt ist es wenn man
politiker ist dann ist man quasi
automatisch im besitz der wahrheit und
wenn man nicht pro liter ist dann
das was salopp ausgedrückt ist eine
problematik die sich bei lukas
gewissermaßen ergibt nun lokal benjamin
hat lukas schmidt interesse rezitiert
wie auch viele andere beispielsweise
heidegger und bei benjamin stellt sich
diese frage dann etwas zugespitzt und
für ihn ist die frage was ist jetzt
erkenntnisse oder vor allem ist es
kritischer erkenntnis wo tut sich die
distanz auf zwischen bewusstsein und
waren bewusstsein marxistisch
ausgedrückt was in die ferne ist
falsches bewusstsein fall weil wie
gesagt für lukas gibt es irgendwie kein
falsches bewusstsein es gibt nur das
bewusstsein des proletariats was
automatisch nicht falsch ist es gibt
natürlich die ideologischen bestrebung
des des bürgertums das versuchen will
denn denn den polit arena zu blenden
aber das ist das ist das ist nicht das
was man meint wenn man überlegt was ist
jetzt ein wahre erkenntnis und was es
nicht war das ist betrifft nur einen
verblendung zusammenhang
ok also jetzt für benjamin stellt sich
die frage im zusammenhang mit der kunst
was ist hier wahrheit und imbiss am für
kunst zur wahren einsichten
also das ist das ist der hintergrund
das ist der sind die elemente die darauf
hindeuten
dass das management ist wirklich eine
wichtige metaphysischer fragestellung
ist nicht nur seine kunst kritisch das
sicherlich auch aber gut also dann die
frage dann bei benjamin ist wenn man das
modell der zweiten natur sich zu nutze
macht dann ist ein wichtiger aspekt
dieser zeit oder ein bestandteil ein
bestandteil ist eben die kunst und vor
allem die technik der kunst in der
künstlerischen technik zeigt sich ein
element oder wichtig ein fundamentales
element natur also diese der natur die
sich der mensch selber zurecht legt und
die frage ist auch gewissermaßen wie
schon bei lukas aber vor allem bei max
wie entwickelt sich diese technik oder
diese zweite natur dahingehend dass die
erkenntnis fähigkeiten des menschen sich
darauf adäquat richten muss also wie
soll ich jetzt diese zweite erkenntnis
diese zweite natur vor allem hinten im
zusammenhang mit der kunst adäquat
erkennen können und sein beispiel für
diese zweite naturen für die entwicklung
der zweiten natur ist daneben vor allem
der film ok also ich möchte jetzt
einfach dieses mal das fortsetzen was
ich letztes mal begonnen hat nämlich
stichprobenartig die einzelnen
abschnitte des ersten absatzes über die
reproduktion zu kommentieren
und wir waren stark auf in der ersten
version 8 angelangt es geht
sie erinnern sich zunächst einmal um die
und die unterschiede zwischen den
ritualen der kultischen kunst und der
neueren kunst die alte kunst oder die
kunst als ich diese aspekte der zweite
natur die jetzt überholt sind ist die
ist vor allem die einmaligkeit also die
alte kunst ist einmalig und die neuere
kunst lässig reproduzieren also alle
künstler lassen sich reproduzieren aber
es ist gehört zum wesen der neueren
kunst dass ihre produzierbar ist und
gerade in der reproduktion sich als
kunst überhaupt gestaltet und das sieht
man auch darin dass es keine
endgültigkeit mehr geben muss
ein beispiel das hatten wir zuletzt am 8
abseits erkannt diese die tatsache dass
die kunst oder ein kunstwerk in der
neueren formen die endgültig ist und
abschließend ist liegt in der
verbesserungs fähigkeit also es gibt
keinen grund in der neueren kunst die ja
sowieso in einem konstanten fluss von
wiederholbarkeit ergibt dass wir sie
nicht verbessern könnte und dafür ich
vorgeschlagen
ist das modell 30 auch dass so ein gutes
beispiel ist aber trotzdem nicht wenn es
noch eines im gegen statt
im gegensatz zur klassischen auffassung
der musik oder zur neuen klasse als ich
meine die klassische so verstanden die
klassische musik wurde zunehmend zu
einem festen gebilde
also man spielte die noten vorher war
improvisation natürlich schon wichtiger
bestandteil dann aber in der großen
symphonischen tradition des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts waren die noten mehr oder
weniger fest
und da kann man sich vorstellen dass
also dem die improvisation ist da jetzt
nicht mehr möglich und insofern ist das
kunstwerk abgeschlossen
es ist ein großes ganze ist das nicht
mehr verbesserungsfähig ist also eine
wagen europaweite unfallstelle ist in
europa vielleicht ein bisschen anders
aber dass da in der wagner oper ist wird
überhaupt nichts improvisiert also auch
nicht die gespräche sozusagen zwischen
den zwischen den darstellern ist ja
alles für ist ok aber in jazz ist meine
wie gesagt eigentlich ist das eine
rückkehr zu einer früheren ordnung aber
trotzdem das kann man als beispiel
werden hat wenn es auch unfähigkeit oder
einer veränderungsfähigkeit ziehen dass
das gas auf relativ lockere strukturen
basiert wie man immer wieder verbessern
und ändern kann also auch ganz
grundsätzlich also auch die harmonischen
strukturen von k s sind keineswegs fest
und unverrückbar also von einzelnen
stücken oder lila ok also das müssen
sich selber überlegen inwiefern sie
jetzt überzeugende beispiele finden
aber das wäre vielleicht ein gewisser
ansatz gut aber jetzt jetzt machen wir
mal weiter
die frage ist die frage ist dann ist
mach jetzt weiter mit
mit dem 10 die frage ist was ist an
dieser reproduktion dass kunst künstler
kunden kunst mäßige also die frage ist
sagt an von gesinnten absatzes
traditionell gesehen hat man ein
künstler bei einer gegenwelt gemaltes
bild das an der wand hängt das ist kunst
ich reproduziere dieses bild aber diese
reproduktion ist keine kunst
ja also ich habe reproduktion in dem
zusammenhang hat nichts kunst haft ist
man sich aber vorausgesetzt wir
verstehen film als in irgendeiner form
kunden ist dann ist die frage wo ist der
ort der künstlerischen leistung
was sind diese im film produzierten
vorgänger die da sieht auch keine
kunstwerke sind also das ist der weitere
pumpe in der klassischen kunst hat man
ein kunstwerk ein bild und man
reproduziert ist und die report des
reproduzieren fühlt nichts hinzu im film
das ist ein bisschen anders weil das
heißt reproduziert wird kein kunstwerk
es doch ben m in jedem fall also das was
der darsteller macht ist kein kunstwerk
na ja man könnte vielleicht schon sagen
es ist so eine künstlerische leistung
was der darsteller macht aber zu
benjamins these gehört hier
auch die der gegensatz zwischen der
bühnen vorstellung bühnenaufführung
eines stücks und der verfilmung vorher
auf der bühne ist also wie bei wagen als
europa und musik und so weiter das ist
dann ein geschlossenes stück und das
cool dass kunst mäßige in einer bühnen
vorstellung hängt auch unmittelbar
zusammen mit diesem organischen ganzen
was auch einmalig ist also ich spiele
das das stück und das damit ist es
fertig meine ich am nächsten tag noch
einspielen aber das ist nicht
reproduktion das ist wiederholung oder
vielleicht wiederholungen das ist jedes
mal jedes mal anders meine das ist der
grund warum man könnte man sagen
überhaupt ins theater geht weiß jedes
mal neu ist also wenn es immer identisch
wäre dann hätte man weniger neigung ich
weiß es nicht aber ebenfalls ist ist es
gefühl oder der gedanke
theatervorstellungen bühnen darstellung
ist als geschlossenes ganzes ein
kunstwerk aber im film das auch benjamin
also das was die khs aufnehmen
es ist eigentlich kein kunstwerk sondern
es sind immer nur einzelne teile also
bruchstück es ist jetzt so bei einem
schwimm oder selten es kann schon mal
vorkommen aber meistens ist einen film
zusammen gebastelt als sehr vielen
einzelnen aufnahmen die der kater dann
zu einem einem ganzen zusammenfügt gut
aber dann
dann sagt ok angesichts dieser vielen
fragmente was ist daran oder wo liegt
daran die kunst mäßige leistung
und da hat er also da ist ein argument
so dass er sagt das ist also er sagt das
ist immer noch absatz 10
es ist ein versuch im angesicht der
apparatur die menschlichkeit
beizubehalten
also das klingt ein bisschen ablehnend
aber der gedanke ist dass der mensch
sozusagen also hier
wie gesagt das ist jetzt zweiter natur
es ist nicht die unmittelbare
menschlichkeit das gibt es vielleicht
gar nicht sondern ist es eine
menschlichkeit team zusammengestellt
wird
aus diesen fragmenten also der die
arbeit des carter ist der schnitt das
ist also darin lässt sich das kunst
mäßige erblicken oder dass es lässt das
kunst mäßige erscheint dadurch dass eine
neue welt oder quasi eine zweite natur
zusammen geschnitten wird
ja und das bezeichnet er als test also
die apparatur also die ganzen kameras
usw stellen einen test da ich weiß das
ist ein etwas ich weiß nicht wo gerade
diesen begriff her hat also er bringt
nun vergleich zum sport also sport
beinhaltet auch tests also ich messe
mich gegen gegen gegen andere
gegen schon schon vorangegangene
leistung und das ist gewissermaßen ein
test aber wieso lässt sich das mit mit
den leistungen des darstellers
vergleichen
na gut also die situation ist vergleich
ist vielleicht vergleichbar so sport
auch damals schon wurde sehr oft
filmisch aufgenommen und insofern kammer
das bisschen vergleichen
naja gut also dass ist ebenfalls ob mann
ob man benjamins darstellung der oder
analyse des films unbedingt 100 prozent
übernimmt das ist vielleicht eine andere
frage aber der gedanke ist es ist jetzt
nicht mehr so dass der große darsteller
der künstler darsteller auf der bühne
steht und mit voller vollendeter kunst
shakespeare oder goethe oder was auch
immer deklamiert sondern der künstler
sowie das wenn wir das jetzt darstellt
ist eigentlich nur sich selbst also
stellt quasi dann sein körper zur
verfügung und führt gewisse bewegungen
aus aber das wird dann fragmentarisch
aufgenommen und dann wieder ganz
zusammen geschnitten auf eine art und
weise was mit dem was mit keiner
ursprünglichen realität was zu tun hat
also die ursprüngliche realität wie man
geschlossen
auf der bühne wahrnehmen kann die
existiert hier gar nichts sondern es
sind nur bruchstückhafte begegnungen
zwischen einem menschlichen körper und
einer apparatur
das nennt und dass das nennt er test
test ist dann insofern des kritisierende
messende aufnehmen von bestimmten
vorgängen die im lichte dieses dessert
geht der ergebnisse von diesen test dann
zusammengefügt werden können zu einer
montierten filmen gesamtheit okay lesen
sie was sie über sich selber und die
werden da auch zur eigenen ergebnissen
kommen aber der punkt ist wie gesagt ist
es was er hier beschreibt ist weit
entfernt von der von von der moralischen
einmaligkeit also in der klassischen
kunst habe ich dieses einzigartige
einmalige vorstellen schon von hier ist
es eine eine zusammenführung von
mehreren wiederholungen oder
reproduktionen also reproduziert wird
hier zum einen die die einzelnen
aufnahmen also jede aufnahme ist eine
reproduktion des von dem was der was der
darsteller macht und das ganze wird dann
noch mal reproduziert
neben in dem einen film daraus montiert
wird und der film oder gerade das
brennen jetzt punkt ist der ganze punkt
eine ganze sinn
des lebens ist dieses ist diese
reproduktion also zweistufig oder was
auch immer gerade in der reproduktion
ist eine ist die kunst zu erkennen okay
das ist jetzt ist ein ausgangs argument
dann geht er weiter und versucht damit
politik mit seinem mit den politischen
vorstellungen ein bisschen zu verbinden
also sie erinnern sich für lukas ist das
politische ein bestandteil des erkennens
also wenn als auch das polit areal ist
das objekt der erkenntnis dann ist das
ja ein politisches element wenn jemand
versucht diese vorstellung jetzt im
zusammenhang mit dem film ein bisschen
weiter zu spinnen
der gedanke ist also also der film ist
eine maschinelle reproduktion des
menschen dahingehend dass einst eine
zweite natur entsteht
das ist dann wiederum zumindest stark
analog zum zu der entwicklung der
industriellen technik also zu den zur
entwicklung der produktionsmittel wie
wir schon besprochen hatten also die
produktionsmittel entwickeln sich im
verlauf der kapitalistischen entwicklung
oder generell
aber es sie entwickeln entwickeln sich
bis zu dem punkt dass die
gesellschaftlichen die
produktionsverhältnisse nicht mehr
vereinbar sind mit dem mit den
produktionsmitteln entsteht spannungen
zwischen produktionsmitteln und
produktionsverhältnisse und diese
spannungen sieht man beispielsweise
darin die industrie erfordert hoch
organisierte und technisch ausgebildete
personen die aber gerade in dieser
organisation sich selber zu einem
aktiven politik selbstbewussten politik
entwickeln
also das ist quasi der grundgedanke bei
marx übrigens ich weiß ich hab sie
gesehen haben in den letzten paar weiß
auch nicht ob das ein gutes beispiel ist
aber sie haben wahrscheinlich gesehen
dass die mitarbeiter von google jetzt
protestiert haben gegen den arbeitgeber
google vom verteidigungsministerium in
den usa aufträge bekommen sollte uns das
gesehen also das
verteidigungsministerium das
amerikanische us
verteidigungsministerium wollte google
irgendwelche aufträge geben ich glaube
es gegen drohnen oder um künstliche
intelligenz die in diesen drohnen
eingesetzt werden sollte damit die
drohnen und dann feinde identifizieren
können und dann
mit raketen erledigen es gibt ja schon
längst aber google sollte einen
derartigen auftrag bekommen die
mitarbeiter haben protestiert und google
hat dann auch den auftrag verzichtet ist
das ein marxistisches beispiel weiß es
nicht genau aber es ist jedenfalls so
dass man dass die google mitarbeiter zu
den hoch qualifizierte qualifiziertesten
überhaupt bohlen naja vielleicht gut
eben wie man sie gehören
und gerade in dieser hohen auf diesen
dieser hohen stufe der qualifikation
entsteht ein bewusstsein ein moralisches
bewusstsein pflichtbewusstsein das den
interessen des arbeitgebers also das
kapital ist widerspricht also das ist
dass es das ist quasi möglicherweise
etwas was was der marxismus vorwegnimmt
weil sie die aber jedenfalls hier haben
wir diese gleiche spannung im rahmen des
service sagt benjamin jedenfalls also
der punkt mit dem film ist der film
lässt sich bis brauchen also dazu kommen
wir später aber hier geht es auch um die
frage wie geht es dem wie geht es den
menschen überhaupt im rahmen der
filmproduktion also im rahmen der
kapitalistischen industrieproduktion der
der arbeiter steht am fließband und
macht nix den ganzen tag
welche die stumpfsinnigen handlungen
wiederholen und das ist etwas was markt
bekanntlich als selbst entfernt und
bezeichnet also der mensch der mensch
ist war da und lebt und handelt und
arbeitet und wer die geld und so weiter
aber was er da tut hat mit ihm selbst
kaum etwas zu tun oder ist es im
gegensatz zum handwerker
klassischerweise der der auch mit mit
mit seinem werk sich identifizieren kann
der fließbandarbeiter kann das nicht
mehr und das ist etwas was mag das
selbstentzündung bezeichnet genau
dasselbe sagt benjamin moment zurück
also selbstentfremdung ist nicht
unbedingt an sich etwas verkehrt ist
weil selbst entwendung ist ist ja an
sich nur ein aspekt der arbeitsteilung
und arbeitsteilung brauchte industrie
damit sie überhaupt so effizient
arbeiten kann wie man klassische seit
adam smith was wahrscheinlich auch
stimmt aber das problem mit der selbst
entfernen ist weniger das
oder dass einige menschen stumpfsinnige
am fließband wiederholen müssen sondern
dass darüber gar nicht hinauskommen das
sieht für sich keine kein
selbstbewusstsein entwickeln können
vor allem natürlich dass sie sich mit
dieser arbeit näher definieren können
weil die die früchte dieser
stumpfsinnigen arbeit
dies ließen alle anderen zugute gut also
zunächst mal halten hat das dasselbe
beim filmen sagt benjamin und zwar das
was wir gerade besprochen hatten nämlich
dieses also stumpfsinnig ist es nicht
unbedingt aber aber die aufnahmen
bezieht sich immer nur auf fragmente
also der der darstellung keine ahnung
also oder wie benjamin shrek oder
irgendwas darstellen und diese eine
aufnahme also erfindet man versuchte den
den darsteller dahin zu bringen dass das
er schreckt zum ausdruck erschreckend
zum ausdruck bringt aber es ist nicht
wirklich erschrecken es ist nur der soll
seine gesichtszüge so erziehen dass das
der betrachter der kinogänger an das
versteht als rack aber das ist nicht
schreckt es ist nur eine aufnahme und
das sagt wenn ihr mann ist das kann man
auch als selbstentfremdung verstehen
genau wie die die einzelnen ansicht
stumpfsinnigen und bedeutungslosen
handlungen handgriffe am fließband ist
auch sind auch diesen momenten momentan
momentanen oder flüchtlingen aufnahmen
für den darsteller
aber sagt benjamin genau wie gleiche
motiv wie bei marx dass diese
selbstentfremdung kann eine höchst sache
zitat in eine höchst produktive
verwertung erfahren
ja also das ist quasi noch eine ein
rückgriff auf das was sie gerade
besprochen hatten diese
selbstentfremdung ist ein sich aus die
aus der imaginären natürlichkeit
zurücknehmen
eine neue zweite natur entstehen zu
lassen und sich dann oder diese neue
zweite natur quasi als kunstwerk setzen
zu können also potenzial nicht immer das
selbstentfremdung ist nicht nur auf
dieser basis und das oder nicht nur in
ihren zu erblicken sondern lässt sich
von passion und oder oder die zweite
natur oder die der eigentliche sinn
das positive an dieser sex entfernt er
blickt man nur oder entsteht nur unter
weiteren die benjamin dann später
spricht hier nochmal das ist jetzt
in abschnitt 1 absatz sagte zitiert er
rudolf arnheim und sorgt die letzte
entwicklung ist den schauspieler wie ein
requisit zu behandeln dass man
charakteristisch auswählt und an der
richtigen stelle einsetzt also das ist
wieder schauspieler als requisit also
der bühnendarsteller ist nie ein
requisit sondern es quelle von emotionen
und und schönen mitreißend informationen
aber hier der filmschauspieler ist ein
requisit man wählt einfach
irgendjemanden aus weil er oder sie
halten irgendwie passen das gesicht hat
und fehlt dieses gesicht immer wieder
mal und montiert das ganze zusammen und
dann hat man seinen sehen das ist
natürlich ein bisschen zugespitzt
ausgedrückt
ich weiß nicht ob das unbedingt stimmt
aber jedenfalls ist ist das dann wieder
dieser gedanke die natürlich das
natürlich charakterlich charakterlich
eine eigene des darstellers oder der
rolle besser gesagt der rolle fällt
zugunsten einer komplexen apparatur
bedingten technik die einzelne fragmente
zusammenmontiert ja also das wissen wir
schon aber hier
das ist dann benjamin technik oder
reproduktionstechnik und der neuen kunst
also darin unterscheidet sich der film
grundlegend
von von der früheren kunst sagt okay so
die die die weitere frage stellen ist
was hat das jetzt mit der politik zu tun
wie kann man aus diesem zusammenhang
also auf der einen ebene
selbstentzündung zweiter natur und frage
mental also nicht mehr natürlich montage
von fragmenten das ist ein aspekt aber
wo ist jetzt die politische dimension um
die sbb auch geht in diesen in diesem
zusammenhang dann stellt er im zwölften
abschnitts die these auf dass es hier um
ausstellungs bedingungen geht wie gesagt
die krise der demokratie lässt sich als
eine krise der ausstellungs bedingungen
des politischen menschen verstehen
ok und hier kommen wir unseren eigenen
zeitalter wieder mehr weil er sagt also
dass das das problem was er hier
aufwirft im zwölften abschnitt ist das
sagt es kommt eine neue auslese eine
auslese vor der apparatur aus der der
champion der star und der diktator als
sieger hervorgehen
also was der film macht ist das quasi
das traditionelle
erwähnt als beispiel die parlamente im
politischen bereich die ja mit den
theatern im künstlerischen bereich
vergleicht also in beiden feldern und
sagt also dieses unmittelbar authentisch
natürlich das authentisch natürlich dass
man auf der bühne oder auf dem parlament
hat verödet warum weil die ausstellung
des politischen menschen sich verändert
also früher hat sich der politische
mensch aus im parlament ausgestellt und
hat die zitrone
was haben wir auch immer in reissende
reden gehalten und seine und ihn mit
parlamentariern überzeugt oder auch
nicht also dieses dieses bild doch
dieses bild verändert sich im bei der
oder im zuge der veränderten
ausstellungs bedingungen etwas seltsamer
begriff aber die ausstellungs
bedingungen des politischen menschen
sind im pulli unmittelbar politischen
waren parlament und sind jetzt ja was
denn also heutzutage so lässt sich das
natürlich leicht zahlen das ist sind
dann twitter filme auf twitter oder
filme auf youtube
das sind die ausstellungs bedingungen
für heute und das hat sich damals auch
schon das wurde damals antizipiert durch
die band auch durch die nicht die
tagesschau hieß es also im kino hat man
immer die nachrichten gesehen
früher bevor es überall fernsehen gab
die wochenschauen oder wochenschauen gut
also das war der erste ansatz zu diesen
neueren neuen ausstellungs bedingungen
politisch wirksam war dann nicht mehr
wie gesagt der einzelne politiker im
kreis anderer
politiker in relativ kleinen kreis im
parlament sondern auf einmal die
filmische der filmische auftritt des
politikers und das sagt benjamin bedingt
eine neue auslese was der der champion
der star der diktator als sieger hervor
das ist eine ganz starke partie
was machen wir dann was machen wir damit
oder warum ist das so und was läuft da
falsch
dann geht er wieder zurück im
dreizehnter abschnitt auf die frage wo
ist jetzt hier die wahrheit
was wäre dann wahrheit und was ist die
ideologie also den referee verwendet er
nicht der erste anlauf im ersten anlauf
in 13 abschnitt sagt er
und das müssen wir lernen also wir
müssen mit diesen lernen mit den medien
umzugehen
und er sagt die fundamental für diesen
neuen ausstellungs bedingungen ist es
die unterscheidung zwischen auto und
publikum ihren grundsätzlichen charakter
verliert das ist dann auch relativ
bekannt früher gab es einen autor und er
hatte seine
leserschaft in großer zahl sogar einen
auto und viele leser das verändert sich
aber weil es nicht mehr nur einzelne
leser einzelne autoren gibt sondern
jeder leser hat die möglichkeit selbst
als autor zu werden
die unterscheidung zwischen auto und
publikum ist insofern sagt benjamin nur
eine funktionelle von fall zu fall so
oder anders verlaufen
jeder kann und das ist heutzutage noch
deutlicher als damals ich meine damals
war es schon so auch so dass man
leserbriefe schreiben konnte und so
weiter die abgedruckt oder auch nicht
abgedruckt wurden
aber heute kann jeder auf facebook oder
youtube oder wo auch immer
seine kommentare abgeben dazu sagt
benjamin
darin kommt die arbeit selbst zu wort
ja okay gut also wir haben jetzt nicht
mehr den den den genialen schöpfer auf
der einen seite und die vielen
präsidenten dieses genie dieser chemie
arbeiten sondern jeder kann daran
teilnehmen und jeder im sinne von
gegenseitiger reflektion und kritik
trägt dazu bei dass dieses mal sind es
jetzt kunstwerke nicht unbedingt aber
jedenfalls medialen erscheinungen sich
entwickeln und das ist positiv zumindest
wie gesagt in dem szene weil hier die
arbeit wie benjamin sagt die arbeit
selbst zu wort kommt und das ist doch da
auch das geschieht im interesse der
selbst und der klassen erkennen ist also
das ist jetzt ein bisschen lokal schafft
das proletariat sozusagen erblickt sich
selbst dass wenn das proletariat aktiv
auf politische ereignisse reagiert indem
es likes abgibt oder kommentare oder
oder darüber
das dient auch der klassen erkenntnis
also jedenfalls ich denke in diese
richtung würde benjamin
heute denken allerdings sagt er das kann
man verfälschen auf moment korruptiven
weg sagte also dieses dieses berechtigte
interesse der massen auch zitat benehmen
an selbsterkenntnis oder klassen
erkenntnis sehr lukas hier kann man
verfälschen
dadurch dass man nochmal zitat
illusionäre vorstellungen und
zweideutige spekulationen stachel ok
entspricht fake news wohl illusion ihre
vorstellungen zweideutige spekulationen
weg news und und verschwörungstheorien
ja das hat sich damals alles schon
abgezeichnet und einen ein mittel dafür
dazu äußerte sich nicht besonders aber
eine ein klassischer playoffs
zusammenhangs ist das liebe liebesleben
der stars also wenn man das betont und
darstellt also dass das wollen die leute
vor allem hören wie es den stars geht
wie schlecht oder gut wie ihr
liebesleben aussieht das ist sicherlich
so wenn ihr meine guckt liebe fälschung
wenn er menschen anspruch von sechs
werke und mir erscheint auch sagen dass
anständige konform hier wurden zwischen
selbsterkenntnis und lassen
erkenntnisstand sind also dass dann auch
die jüngst gar nicht nach dem preis
situation ist wie bei kassierte und zum
beispiel das ist ja selbst erkenntnissen
klassen erkenntnis also ich würde nur
sagen erst mal ich wollte noch ein
bisschen was zu sehen später abschnitten
sagen
benjamins modell ist dann am ende
weniger also ein klassisches
selbsterkenntnis ja gewissermaßen aber
im rahmen also sein modell was ihm
vorschwebt es die ist die psychoanalyse
und zwar sowohl gemeinsamen klassen
erkenntnis als auch selbsterkenntnis
also das ist eine gewisse frage wie
erfolgreich das sein kann das modell der
psychoanalyse aber wenn einfach erstmal
dabei ein positives selbsterkenntnis
sind wieder persönlich unmittelbar oder
oder gesellschaftlich ist schwebt den
schon vor als als erstrebenswert ja okay
was das ist jetzt auch noch ein
dreizehnter abschnitt aber ich glaube
dass man sich jeder selber erlassen
überlassen zu im detail zu lesen er sagt
jeder kunstform steht im schnittpunkt
von entwicklungslinien und er erwähnt
die technik nur ein absatz und es ist
nicht so wahnsinnig klar was er was er
damit sagen
aber der punkt ist normal das argument
die technik also die konkrete konkret
konkreten techniken womit die kunst
hergestellt wird sind letztendlich
bestimmen oder zur weitgehend bestimmen
dafür wie
kunst wahrgenommen wird und wie die
kunst das künstlerische überhaupt zur
wahrnehmung oder zur erkenntnis
beitragen kann oder erkenntnis darstellt
er erwähnt an dieser stelle die da da
ist und jacqueline vorbei das macht also
was er damit
darunter versteht erscheint später im
größeren detail also jetzt noch hier
nicht zu lange aus aufzuhalten
m14 abschnitt geht es um die blaue blume
und montage die blaue blume ist ein bild
sozusagen oder sein ironischer hinweis
auf die romantische kunst technik also
blaue blume beinahe wahl ist also das
was der mensch entdeckt wenn er also das
wahre an seiner natur oder dem weg
dorthin zurück findet denn wie gesagt
hier ironisch gesagt dass entsprechende
was in der modernen vielen teils nicht
hergestellt wird ist dieses diese enorm
komplexe apparatur woran sehr viele
leute teilnehmen also wie sie wissen im
abspann zu filmen konnten konnten diese
ewigen liste der mitarbeitenden dem
jeweiligen
und das ist es dass diese bedienen alle
die apparatur
aber was da als ergebnis hat dabei
herauskommt also der film selbst im film
sieht man das alles nicht sondern man
sieht nur etwas was ohne ohne apparat
scheinbar erstellt wurde und dann heißt
es bei ihm
der apparat freie aspekt der realität
ist hier zu ihrem künstlich ssten
geworden
und der anblick der unmittelbaren
deutlichkeit zu der blauen blume im
lande der technik also ich sehe da was
und denke mir ja das ist frappierende
natürlichkeit aber ist das ist es ja
gerade nicht das ist partout künstlich
aber das ist jeder der die thematik der
zweiten natur an die herstellung der
zweite natur vor allem durch montieren
das wird hier alles noch dargestellt und
da kommt auch das bekannte bild zwischen
dem vergleich mit dem chirurg und im
praktischen arzt oder dem magier der
magier erhält dadurch dass er hand
anlegt aber eine distanz bewahrt
zwischen sich und den patienten der
chirurg als gegenpol halt in dem er in
den patienten hinein greift bau
schneidet und das eine also der magier
ist es ist auch sicher und hat eine
wertvolle wertvolle anders es geht hier
nicht um bewährte aber das ist quasi die
vergleichbar mit dem mit der
traditionellen mit dem tradition und
traditionell umgang mit der kunst also
dass rieter das ritual das auratische
das magisch ich nähere mich der sache
nicht so sehr sondern aus der ferne
verspüre ich dieses arabische auf der
anderen seite dass der chirurg der mit
seinen apparaten mit seinem messer an
und so weiter esprit mit dem patienten
hinein greift und dadurch eine heilung
herstellt oder etwas positives herstellt
und der chirurg ist hier das hier als
eine analogie gesehen in analogie zu den
reparatur des der filmherstellung okay
ja 15 genießende und und kritische
reaktionen oder behandlung von kunst ja
das ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig
wichtig aber auf einen satz würde ich
sie aufmerksam machen
der punkt meint das hatten wir
gewissermaßen aber hier sagt er noch mal
der punkt mit dieser neueren kunst auf
der eines in der herstellung sind sehr
viele leute involviert und eine
hochentwickelte apparatur das ist die
eine seite auch in der rezeption haben
wir eine mehrzahl also klassisch ist es
der einzige kunst verständige oder oder
der priester der sich an einem bild oder
in einem werk das ist das ist das
klassische bild also wenn er sagt es ist
ganz angenehm wenn ich ihn im museum
alleine bin und das nicht weil touristen
hin und her
daraufhin sondern ich kann nicht einfach
sammeln vor dem bild das ist das ist das
eine die eine möglichkeit der rezession
aber die andere möglichkeit ist hier
betont ist die kollektive rezeption
das ist nicht nur eine kollektive
herstellung sondern ein kollektiver
rezeption und das ist das ist
bezeichnend für die moderne kunst raum
vor allem der film also wenn ich ins
kino gehe dann will ich auch dass andere
leute da sitzen weil wir sitzen alle da
und lachen an derselben stelle oder kann
er noch irgendwas also die reaktion ist
dann gewissermaßen eine ist um eine
kollektive und das wäre dann ein
unterschied sagte es ist jetzt nicht so
weit ausgeführt aber eben das ist dass
an dieser stelle thema und er sagt meine
das ist immer das problem es werden hier
ansprüche aufgestellt die nicht
unbedingt einlösbar sind aber er sagt
dass dieses dass das publikum bei diesen
neueren kunstformen im rap city an sich
selbst organisiert und kontrolliert
also das ist wieder dieses marxistische
bild das sind ja mit der neuen technik
entstehen möglichkeiten der selbst des
selbstbewusstseins die vorher nicht
vorher nicht
und das ist hier im zusammenhang mit
diesen mit dem film sagte den die kunst
rezipienten beispielsweise die leute im
kino organisieren und kontrollieren sich
selber vielleicht ein bisschen also
ebenfalls tendenz in die richtung
vielleicht noch mehr in den sozialen
medien kommt mal sagen ich meine
facebook wird ja verwendet um
ich weiß es nicht also politische
bewegung oder demonstrationen zu
organisieren
das ist dann schon gewissermaßen
organisation und kontrolle von sich
selbst aber ist jetzt facebook kunst na
ja das sind das müssen sie sich selber
völlig okay dann kommt es zu diesen
punkt mit der psychoanalyse
er sagt das ist jetzt ab 16
ich werde ihnen das ist ein bisschen
darstellen und dann glaube ich für
dieses mal auf also 16 psychoanalyse er
sagt da geht es darum was erblicken wir
empfinden
und da geht es darum dass wir jetzt
nicht so quasi ein bewusstes analysieren
von der realität vorfinden sondern sogar
handgreiflich das ist eine andere natur
ist die zu der kamera als die zum auge
spricht okay das wissen wir schon geht
es weiter anders vor allem so dass an
die stelle eines von menschen mit
bewusstsein durch
akten raum ist ein unbewusst durchwirkt
es ist zunächst mal nicht ganz so
einfach nachzuvollziehen aber der
gedanke ist in der klassischen kunst ist
alles sehr bewusst das ist klarheit und
deutlichkeit und ich verwende die kunst
um irgendein bestimmten gegenstand
wahrhaft zu erkennen
das ist ein mit bewusstsein durchweg
torraum aber sagt im film ist das jetzt
ist das nicht mehr so es ist ein
unbewusst durch wirkt da und das daran
denkt da an filme oder die andere die
fähigkeit des films so fantasie
entstehen zu lassen also durch das
montieren von fragmenten entstehen also
jetzt nicht fehlen und und hexen und so
weiter aber dass die welt selbst die
verfilmt wird zu einem ja sagt unbewusst
durchwirkten raum entsteht
um das und das genau zu verfolgen was
hat das passagenwerk zu hilfe nehmen
das machen wir dann später aber der ist
eine ganze analyse der analyse der der
architektur in paris der passage
einkaufsgassen beruht darauf dass er
sagt es ist das unbewusste des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts dass ich hier
im baulich zum ausdruck bringt ja und
genau das gleiche sagt er jetzt über den
film das dass das was hier was im film
dargestellt wird oder dargestellt werden
kann oder der aktuell werden sollte ich
weiß nicht ob das jetzt press kollektiv
ist das ist dass unser raum in einer ja
gut also von der unmittelbaren
wirklichkeit oder von dem was hier
zunächst also ich dir raus auf die
straße und sie die die ludwigstraße oder
was auch immer also das ist quasi der
unmittelbare wahrnehmung aber im film
sowie der diese bilder zusammen montiert
werden wird es so etwas was was so
benjamin ein unbewusst durch wirkt der
raum ist gut unbewusst in frechen sinne
also nicht unbewusst im sinne von
ja keine ahnung was da ist sondern
unbewusst in dem sinne dass das ist
unbewusste hier wird und deswegen genau
wie im innerdeutschen psychoanalyse ist
es die aufgabe der cdu ist es die
aufgabe des des kritischen wahrnehmens
dass ich das sprechende saft oder oder
oder zu einer zu einer er sich aus dem
schlechten dass das aus dem unbändigen
sozusagen es kann sich so auszudrücken
des traums herauskomme und der wache
also das ist das ist die thematik von
von diesem abschnitt
und er sagt wie gesagt ist das sind
vielleicht zu wenig beispiele sind die
beispiele was weiß ich selber suchen und
ich denke jetzt heute 80 jahre später
einem de die beispiel da noch viel mehr
einfallen können aber sein beispiel ist
zufrieden
tallinn auf der einen seite da ist und
dann schaltpläne und er sagt zu den
beiden also die da ist mit ihrem
künstlerischen projekt des anstoß
erregen dass die leute das versuchen die
leute durch schock aus ihrer starre zu
befreien
gewissermaßen vielleicht aus dem dem
traum erwachen zu lassen das unterstellt
ebenfalls bände - es auch als ziel der
dabei ist und er sagt im film ist das
entsprechender templin verdienen für ihn
ist ein modell
der politischen satire ja gut also nur
noch eine bemerkung dann höre ich auf
und das ist die frage dass der gegensatz
zwischen sammlung und zerstreuung das
hatten wir jetzt gewissermaßen also
sammlung ist das was der kunstkenner
macht der zerstörung ist das was die
kollektivität beispielsweise im kino
nacht war ein weiteres beispiel sagte es
gab schon immer dieses kollektive
wahrnehmen in der kunst früher
vornehmlich oder vielleicht
ausschließlich in der architektur
architektur ist für ihn ein modell
dieses unbewussten oder der wahrnehmung
oder der des erlebens vom unbewussten
weil architektur bauwerke nehme ich
nicht jetzt unbedingt außer ich bin
kunstkenner oder architekt nehme ich
nicht war es gegenstände der analyse
sondern irgendwie unbewusst also der und
zwar als mitglied eines kollektivs die
leute die einen ein bauwerk nutzen
es sind immer also nicht jetzt einzelne
wohnhäuser sondern beispielsweise
universitäten es ist immer ein
kollektives fließen
die personen rein und raus und in dieser
zerstreuung also zerstreuung jetzt
zweifachen sinne als nicht konzentriert
aber auch zerstreut als weil das bauwerk
sie zwingt drumherum sich zu zerstreuen
und nicht sie verstehen schon okay und
dieses zerstreuen
beim bauwerk ist auch ein beispiel für
das was er als taktile wahrnehmung
bezeichnet also das taktile oder das
klassische kunstwerk oder ja was heißt
klassisch nicht über die kasse des
konventionelle vielleicht sogar
reaktionäre kunstwerk beispielsweise
bilder in einem museum sind nicht aktiv
ich gebe ein und schaue sie mir an und
sammle mich und konzentrieren
dieses kunstwerk aber es ist nicht
taktisch taktile ist dabei es berührt
mich nicht
das ist aber in der rezeption durch
zerstreuung anderes weil das taktile
also dass die berührung oder in
benjamins darstellung die schockwirkung
es wird das erschrecken
aus dieser erfahrung das ist etwas
erschreckendes ein beispiel das
taktieren vielleicht ein anderes
beispiel des taktilen ist gerade in
einem bauwerk bin wenn ich am mauer an
der mauer vorbei gehen weiß oder oder
da gegenstöße dass es natürlich taktile
ist und in ein bild an der wand hat
diese wirkung nicht mehr sagt eben in
der in der kunst oder in der der
bisherige oder ein beispiel für dieses
taktile ist der dadaismus das schränke
das erschrecken oder oder anstoß erregen
will und das ist etwas was auch für den
film bezeichnet ist bei der die abfolge
von uns ermittelten und vielleicht auch
schock erzeugenden bildern auf im film
ist ebenfalls ein beispiel für diese
zerstörung also die die die zuschauer
die in einem horrorfilm sitzen und
erschrecken wenn wenn wenn die monster
erscheinen das ist eine taktile
wahrnehmung der kunst und keine
gesammelte kontemplative wahrnehmen
ok auch da muss man sich überlegen wie
gut anwendbar ist also wenn jemand
versucht die sind mit diese diese brücke
zu schlagen zwischen auf der einen seite
elemente der technische elemente
technisch bedingt elemente des films vor
allem und politischen erwägungen oder
jedenfalls bewerten
oder sagen wir mehr als politisch
moralisch vielleicht also praktisch im
praktischen sinne praktischen erwägungen
praktischen bewertungen mit der mit der
allgemeinen frage ist kann man sagen
dass die kunst moralisch oder politisch
aggressiv sein kann ist oder sein kann
das ist eine schwierige frage wie weit
wir hier andere antworten finden können
weiß ich nicht aber die fragestellung
ist ist ohnehin der anregend und ich
meine die einfachere anwendungen auf der
of news und soziale medien und so weiter
und so weiter das ist klar da braucht
man keine große kein großes
theoretisches gerüst dazu aber benjamin
wie man will natürlich mehr als dass wir
schon sagen dass es die neue die heutige
konzerte die kunst die sich heute auf
der grundlage der neuen technik anbieten
die es wirklich was ganz anderes
es ist eine software irgendwo eine
historische umweltzone und dadurch wird
auch unsere welt für uns anders okay das
ist der anspruch
wie erfolgreich benjamin mit dieser
darstellung ist das muss jeder für sich
selber entscheiden
okay gibt es fragen
und